hi everyone I'm Jonathan Johnson today I
got another tactical challenge for you
so when you see the position on your
screen go ahead pause your video and
good luck solving it in this position
it's black to move I'll wait about five
to ten seconds before I give away the
solution but if you need a little extra
time just pause the video and see if you
can solve it alright so in this position
what black kind of wants to do is he
wants to take the bishop on c3 but then
obviously the knight would take back
also we have some dreams of moving our
bishop out of the way so we can take the
knight on e4 but of course we'd have to
find a good Bishop move so hopefully you
guys were able to solve it the
surprisingly strong move in this
position is Bishop to e5 so if you're
able to find this move then you're
almost certain to win the game here the
problem is you can't move either the
knight or the bishop without losing the
other one so for example if you play
Bishop takes e5 simply we take on e4 and
we'll take the piece on e5 on the next
turn and we'll win a piece conversely if
you protect your knight for example well
now we can take on e4 and after the
bishop takes back we take on c3 forking
the king and rook guaranteeing that we
win some material here and in the final
position black is up a piece and should
go on to win the game thank you
everybody for watching this video
hopefully a lot of you were able to
solve it out there I know this one was a
pretty tricky one so a big congrats to
everyone that was able to get it right
and if you want to see more great chess
content just like this hit like share
subscribe and we'll see you next week
for another tactical challenge